good morning good afternoon and good
evening from wherever you are calling in
um i want to thank lap roots for
providing the opportunity for us
to speak today my name is iron art and
i'm a customer technology advisor
at resolve biosciences and at resolve
biosciences we are developing molecular
cartography which is a highly sensitive
and highly multiplexed spatial
transcriptomics platform
and i will be uh talking more about how
we can use our platform really to
empower scientists uh to to discover the
next breakthroughs in in their research
and more specifically i will be talking
about that in the in the context of
neuroscience
how to use our technology to study gene
expression changes in the brain
with spatial contexts
and
you see behind the logo already a little
teaser of
what it actually looks like it's it
looks like a piece of art and i think
it's absolutely uh beautiful
but what it actually is is a cross
section of the mouse hypocampus and many
of the colors you see are actually
individual molecules individual
transcripts that are colored
based on the genes where they reside
from
so just to dive in deeper on
why
spatial technology is actually very
important and is considered the next
frontier
in our understanding of how how tissues
are composed and how we understand the
cellular heterogeneity
so over the past couple of years as you
may know we
we really um
increased our understanding about the
heterogeneity of different
cell types and tissue through
the revolution of single cell rna-seq
and other technologies and how that
actually basically works is if you have
a tissue
in this case for example a mouse brain
you need to dissociate that tissue so
you need to extract all the individual
cells and you compartmentalize every
individual cell be it in a droplet or in
a microplate
and within each droplet or
well of a microplate you you will
generate cdna generate the library for
sequencing
and this will allow you to to really
profile the transcriptome of each
individual cell and it's a very very
powerful technology
that coming from let's say bulk rna-seq
really
allowed us to understand the cellular
heterogeneity much better and really
allowed for many new discoveries in in
rare cell types and how they respond
to pathology or drugs
etc but of course when dissociating your
tissue it's
it's difficult to know how these cells
relate to each other in a spatial
context you might know where
approximately they are residing so in
this figure you can see maybe the red
cluster you know
these are probably cells originating
from from the cortex in this tissue but
it's difficult really to to use that as
an extra dimension so i think spatial
technology in this sense is really the
next frontier the next dimension we need
to really understand those things so and
how it actually works is you you take
also in this case for example a mouse
brain and you make section
and you will
directly in that section in c2 target
those same
transcripts and really visualize them
within their native contexts
and what you
are allowed to see then is let's say the
same clusters the same populations of
cells that you would normally identify
with single cell rnac
you can actually
look at them in a spatial context how
they relate to each other for example in
this
case how they are organized across the
mouse cortex in different layers and
this
adds a whole new dimension on how we
understand the underlying biology
and within the neuro
neuroscientific context of course as as
posed by by ramon kahl almost a century
ago this will also allow us really to
understand much better the cell to cell
communication which is fundamental to
understanding the different uh networks
and how they
how all these neurons and other cell
types communicate with each other uh
with very high resolution
while maintaining a spatial
dimension here
so i want to walk you through um
apologies so before moving into some
examples i want to make sure that you
understand the importance of the spatial
biology in this context and
it's really
also acknowledged by nature methods
because they announced that spatially
resolved transcriptomics is
the method of the year 2020. and many of
these technologies really are
being developed as we speak and many
companies are are in this space and we
at resolve biosciences truly truly
believe that our
very sensitive and highly highly
multiplexed platform can really empower
scientists to discover new things and
boost their research
so to dive deeper in what is possible
possible with our molecular cartography
technology
so this is a
cross section a coronal section of a
mouse brain so this is taken from the
allen brain atlas and on the left side
you can see
the bright field image and on the right
side is an annotation from the allen
brain atlas depicting the the different
uh areas of
of
the the brain and and really to to
localize that let's say an anatomical
atlas so what we actually did is we used
our technology to profile up to 100
genes in in one sample simultaneously
and we were able to capture more than
8.5 million individual molecules so
superimposed on this image you can see
the visualization of our data set with
all 8.5
million molecules visualized here so if
you would in fact zoom in and i will
show you images later on you can really
pinpoint each individual molecule
separately and this provides a lot of
opportunities to really dive deeper into
this data set and understand
how
the different transcripts but also also
the different cell types are
related to each other
so how did we actually
do this well
our molecular cartography is actually
based on a combinatorial single molecule
fish approach
so
let's say you have a tissue section in
this case again our mouse tissue section
we develop
transcript specific probes for a list of
genes that you can provide so you can
fully customize that
and we hybridize
that tissue with all the transcript
specific probes and we have a
proprietary
chemistry where we are able to color
these transcript
specific probes but also decolor them
and we use that in a sort of cyclical or
repeated imaging cycle
and why do we need
repeated imaging cycles for this because
this actually allows us to
with high confidence
trace back the location of each
transcript and annotate that
transcript to a given gene and so on the
right side you will see a an example of
this an illustration let's say we have
six imaging rounds and in each imaging
round we know beforehand how we design
our probes
what color we would expect in each round
for a given transcript that originates
from a given gene
so for example
transcript
coming from gene a we know up front that
it would
be fluorescent in the green channel then
again in the second round in the green
channel again in round three the red
channel etc etc all the way up until
around six
and at the very end we can just decode
that barcode basically and really
annotate specifically as you can see
here highlighted
in orange where
those transcripts are we can
with high confidence uh identify them as
being originating from gene a in this
example
so it's both very specific but also
highly sensitive because the sensitivity
comes from the fact that it's based on
single molecule fish and i will talk a
bit later on that today as well
but first maybe more about the
specificity
so we compared um this data set with
with older publications uh using
traditional in c2 hybridization
so on the top top panel you see um
many different
marker genes for for cortical layers in
the mouse cortex so
we
were able to nicely nicely recapitulate
that with our technology so on the
bottom panel you see for these
individual genes
very similar expression patterns and
even for for example ctgf on the right
side we can actually see very clearly
that this is a specific marker for layer
6b in the in the mouse cortex but the
big difference here is that the dataset
shown on the low part so so for each
gene we just colored this in green right
but basically
each of these panels are comprising of a
huge data set where we actually
multiplexed up to 100 g so
that data set is much richer and we we
just pick out the the the gene we want
to just visualize that and and and do
further analysis so that adds more um
depth to the data set we have compared
to of course
low multiplexed in situ hybridization
and as for sensitivity so when we
compare that with bulk rna-seq coming
from the human protein atlas rna-seq
database for mouse brain
we can nicely see that there's a good
correlation with the counts we we we
have from the molecular cartography so
genes that are expressed highly in in
the rna-seq data
set will also be highly expressed in our
data set and vice versa for low express
g
but i think more importantly
we want to of course compare that to
another spatial technology and in this
case single molecule fish because it's
considered to be the gold standard and
the most sensitive
spatial technology available to date
so we compared our technology with
single molecule fist just for a couple
of genes
and we we see that the counts per cell
are almost identical so we have similar
sensitivity as compared to single
molecule fish
so let's dive deeper into what we can
learn from
data sets
in neuroscience so again
this is the the mouse brain hemisphere
and within the set of 100 genes that we
selected we just visualize here 13 of
those genes and these 13 genes are
actually markers for the different
cortical layers
and zoomed in centrally in the slide you
can clearly see that
as we expected all these different
markers it's a beautiful rainbow picture
here
but it nicely shows that we are able to
constantly
recapitulate what is known to be
specific for the the different cell
layers and that these that these marker
genes are are nicely located to where we
expect them to be so that's a nice
validation of the the marker genes we
put in and and the validation of our
data set as well
but you can go further so what is nice
is within the same data sets you can
actually
really dive deeper into all the
different cell types so you can clearly
see here that in the different shades of
red we visualize the glutamatergic
neurons
but also in yellow the gabaergic
interneurons
and also microglia astrocytes
oligodendrocytes
so these are all nicely visible in this
data set of course it is a lot the data
is highly dense but it also shows nicely
how many individual data points you're
able to capture just from 35 genes so
not not even the whole data set but you
can still clearly
see already for example in yellow these
gabaergic interneurons nicely
interspersed with with the glutamatergic
neurons beside it
um but of course i think it's it's nice
to dive even deeper into the data and
really
a lot it allows you to just select a
subset of genes you're interested in and
this is a great example of it so if we
only look at certain subtypes of
inhibitory neurons when we just look at
the marker genes for that
for example we have get one or pair of
albumin positive interneurons
somatostatin in yellow and vip
interneurons in in purple you can nicely
appreciate i think the the the
complexity and the way they are
organized and even
especially for the somatostatin
interneurons here you can even see the
projections coming out of the the cell
body here which is a nice um thing to
see if you're interested in neuroscience
to also see all those details popping up
and then importantly here i want to show
you a
visual representation
of one single somatostatin interneuron
and this is really to show that we are
for one uh able to um
to capture 3d information uh in in in
our data sets um and this is nicely
shown by the doppy segmented nuclei
and you see each individual spot
represents one individual transcript
molecule coming from somatostatin you
can nicely appreciate that
even
zooming in into one individual cell like
this it allows you to really
dive deeper into subcellular differences
either within a given cell or comparing
that to other cell types as well so our
resolution is really subcellular uh down
to the single molecule level
so
more downstream analysis of course can
be done and one way to do that is of
course taking that whole data set
and segment out each individual cell of
course segmentation is a topic in itself
it's a very complex topic especially in
neuroscience because all these cells
have very complex shapes
but that's a topic i think for another
webinar
today i want to show you if we just take
a basic cell segmentation based on dapi
we're already
seeing a lot of information popping up
we can generate cell to gene and gene to
cell matrices and what you can see is
per individual segmented cell here we
are able to pick up
hundreds to sometimes thousands of
individual signals per cell and also uh
upwards to 60 sometimes more genes per
cell that are actually expressed and
this is in a panel of 100g so that tells
you already a lot of the
the intricate details of the data set
and and how much information you
actually capture
but using that
using that cell segmentation
what it allows you to do is
really
just like in single cell rna-seq
it allows you to
take that information take that matrix
and do
again uh clustering on that so it's
completely compatible with for example
syrup and in this example on the left
panel you can see
for 35 000 individual cells based on the
100 genes
data set i showed you earlier and you
can see that all these clusters
are very nicely defined and we were able
to
identify all the major
cell types in this and on the right side
you can see the heat map and this rule
will allow you to identify
different marker genes
that are
specific for each individual cluster
but of course
very different from single cell rna
sequence we have here quite
familiar looking data i think but what
is important here is that we always
retain the spatial dimension here and
the spatial structure so what is shown
here is you can always go back and for
example select a certain cluster that
you're interested in interested in
and see how it actually maps
spatially in in this section uh where
you captured the data originally from so
here is an animation that actually shows
all these different clusters being
projected back onto the tissue and this
really allows you to understand much
better how all these individual cells
and these these different cell clusters
are are
spatially mapped and this really
provides
the spatial context whenever it's needed
you can always go back to that again
and this is also represented here in
this slide where
we are nicely able to
visually represent all the different
cell types on on the tissue section
whether it be oligodendrocytes or again
the glutamatergic neurons or micro
microglia you can really appreciate all
the different
spatial organizations of these cell
types
and what you can do because we have the
segmented uh
self-segmented data from that you can
actually just use that clustering and
count all those different cells and see
for example in a simple analysis how
many um glutamatergic neurons are there
compared to other cell types and this we
did this on our data and it really
nicely recapitulates what is known
in in the mouse brain already so it's
again a nice validation of of our
technology and what you can do with it
and and this really opens up the whole
new spatial dimension in in your single
cell data set
but i want to talk also today more about
certain applications
what you can do so for example what we
did here i want to explain a bit more
about
what we did in a collaboration with a
major pharmaceutical company and this
was in the context of alzheimer's
disease so
in alzheimer's disease mouse models what
we what we know from the past couple of
years based on single cell rna-seq is
that um of course in in alzheimer's
disease you have the occurrence of these
amyloid plaques
which is a typical phenomenon of the
pathology there but what was discovered
is that you have a specific subset of
microglia that responds to to this
pathology and they're called
disease-associated microglia and you can
identify these subtypes
using single cell rna-seq but i think
it's very important and it's a very nice
use case of the power of spatial biology
to really understand how these
subtypes of microglia
are are responding to the pathology
where they are located and this can
provide a basis for drug discovery and
really modulating the outcome of disease
and just to give you more insight into
this so on the on the left you can see
a comparison of gene expression between
wild type and an alzheimer's disease
mouse model and on the top you see just
the the depiction of the different cell
types neurons
and microglia as well microglia and
green neurons in blue here and on the
bottom you can see that uh when coloring
the the the same cell populations you
can immediately see big differences and
we see
less neurons uh there in the tissue but
also slight increase in in the green
signals meaning the the microglia
but importantly i want to mention here
as well
in yellow you can see here the amyloid
plaques and what was actually done is we
first ran our molecular cartography a
workflow and after that because during
the workflow we have
we
the tissue is completely intact we
maintain the tissue integrity you can
actually after that analysis you use it
still for immunohistochemistry or
labeling it with a dye and in this case
we labeled it with a pftaa dye
which specifically binds to the amyloid
plaques here depicted in yellow
and on the right side this is another
type of analysis we can just visualize
just all the genes that are enriched in
the wild type cortex versus the
alzheimer mouse model cortex and we can
see that
there are major differences of course
and many of these genes are actually
enriched near the amyloid plaques
and again when we segment out
all these cells using dappy with q-pop
again like mentioned before we can we
can we can generate these umap clusters
and really identify all the different
cell populations and just like you would
do with um single cell rna-seq
is you can compare wild-type versus
admos model
clusters specifically and you can
compare
let's say the effect of pathology in in
in in your transcriptomic readout here
and there are many different differences
across many different populations but
what the spatial component allows you to
do and i will go into detail a bit
further
but it allows you to also measure the
distance
towards the plaque center for each
individual
cell in the in this cluster and this is
just say a heat map and we can see that
for microglia for example on so the top
cluster
you can see that
you have two populations one is
related to the wild type the other one
is related to the ad pathology
you can clearly see that it's also
heavily correlated with the distance
towards the plaque so the closer you go
to the plaque the more you see these
cells going into a disease-associated
phenotype
and you can really dive much deeper into
this analysis and
um when we
zoom out a bit again and we just analyze
all of the frequency of all the
different cell types we can clearly see
that when you compare wild type to ad
mouse model brain
you can see a decreasing glutamatergic
neurons and an increase in the number of
microglia but of course
what is important is you have the
spatial component at
at all times what we did here is we
actually correlated that or quantified
actually the uh the distance towards the
closest plaque for all these different
cell types and on the right panel you
can clearly see that
when you go closer to the plaque center
you can see a decrease in the amount of
glutamatergic neurons and you can see an
increase in the number of microglia this
already hints towards
what is happening in response to
pathology
you can even go
deeper into the data and really check
individual transcript levels
so what we actually did is we analyzed
more than 600 individual plaques across
three different
animals and we drew concentric circles
around the plaque and then we measured
for each
transcript how their levels changed in
relation to the distance to the plaque
so and this allows you also on
individual transcript level to really
assess uh potential markers for
different uh cell types so in this case
this is visualized for a marker gene
that is known to be a marker for the
disease associated microglia you can
clearly see in the middle panel that are
located around the amyloid plaques
and on the right panel is a
quantification of this that you can see
for uh two markers so that marker one
and two in green and red you can see an
increase in their expression the closer
you get to the plaque center and at the
same time for some neural markers you
actually see a decrease and this is a
nice readout to have if you're for
example developing a drug and when a
modulated disease you would also like to
see changes in these transcripts but
also on a
cell type level and things like that so
it's i think a very nice application and
shows the power of spatial biology in
the context of new discoveries in
alzheimer's disease
and again so the previous fight was more
on the transcript level but you can all
always zoom out and really look again at
the different cell types and how they
respond to pathology so on the left side
is again
a data set on the ad mouse model and on
the right side you have the wild types
and if you just
map back the different cell types in
this case for example you can nicely see
on the right with the wild types in
purple the astrocytes that are nicely
distributed along the mouse cortex and
the reactive astrocytes that are
on the outer edges of the cortex
you clearly seen the the mouse model
representative for alzheimer's disease
on the left side that
these reactive astrocytes are now
dispersed throughout the cortex and
again these diseases associated
microglia they pop up as a new
population and they surround the uh the
amyloid plaques again labeled with the
pfda
dye
so you can learn a lot about these cell
different cell clusters how they map
back spatially and how they interact
with
with the pathology in this case
and this is
also an aim this is an ongoing work just
to show you that it's possible to also
do this on on human samples so this is
again in collaboration with a a
pharmaceutical company
to really show differences between uh
control human
brain tissue and and post-mortem
alzheimer tissue in black stage stage
six and you can see here just a snapshot
a teaser basically of the different uh
cell populations we're able to visualize
here and you already see clear
differences in in for example the
expression of neural markers here but
this analysis is ongoing and i hope
maybe in the next webinar
dive deeper in in the in the outcome
here and then what you can discover with
uh with our technology on human brain as
well um this shows you that it's uh that
our technology works in different
species on on different sample types etc
and i want to
summarize what is possible with our
technology basically
we are able to apply our technology to
many different species to many different
types of tissues and also different cell
cultures and and cell types
and we can
probe up to 100 genes simultaneously in
each individual's
sample
what i think is very important is that
we offer a very high resolution so it's
single molecule and we are also able to
provide 3d information
across the tissue section
as for analysis which is a very
important part of the whole spatial
technology field at this moment we
actually provide an interactive software
to really allow you to analyze these
images um very intuitively but also it's
compatible with uh open source platforms
like i showed you like surat and and
things like that to really allow for
many different types of analysis
and i think uh very importantly one spot
is one transcript so it really allows
you to quantify our data digitally
so we don't rely on let's say
fluorescent intensity so this is really
a nice way to quantify your
transcriptomic data in a spatial fashion
we also offer the
possibility to do a multi-omic readout
as i mentioned throughout our essay we
make sure that the the tissue remains
intact so you can do
afterwards you can do immunoisochemistry
or or combine it with dyes with with
other types of readouts and a throughput
in the system we are developing in our
workflow
is actually 24 samples run in parallel
for a 100 genes per sample and i think
our sensitivity as i showed before is
very on par with single molecule fish
and this is also part because we don't
use enzymes
and we don't have like an amplification
bias
inserted in our chemistry and this is
one of the differentiators of resolve
biosciences we actually offer the higher
resolution and the high sensitivity and
this is not always the case for example
when you
look at other spatial technologies that
use
rolling circle amplification or when you
have technologies where you need to
extract the rna with permeabilization
onto onto a glass light for for
sequencing and things like that so we
offer both a high sensitivity and a
higher resolution and we maintain our
tissue integrity of course which allows
you to do much of the downstream
analysis
and i want to
end with just an announcement like how
we work today as we offer an end-to-end
service and support so you are able to
access our technology
in service mode so if you have a gene
list available
you can actually order probes with an
online tool we can support you in that
what we actually do is we send our
special resolve slides to you you uh
section your tissue you put the sections
on top of our
glass light you ship the glass light
back and we run the chemistry in-house
and we provide you with all the data you
need
to analyze in and interpret uh interpret
your important biology and we are there
really to uh support you in in
producing the best biology and really to
boost your research
and i want to end with the last slide if
you are interested in our technology
please drop me an email
if you want to make use of our
end-to-end service again don't hesitate
to contact me and if you have any
questions you can also email but of
course we have a q a lined up as well so
feel free to drop a line there so thank
you very much and have a great day